foreign
thank you for joining us
for today's webinar immune secrets of
the lymph node revealed by spatial
multiomics
my name is Elizabeth Schneider senior
Global Marketing Manager at nashring and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational webinar is presented
by labroots and brought to you by those
of us at nanostring to learn more you
can visit unastring.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
you're experiencing here as well if you
have trouble seeing your hearing the
presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker from
Nana string Jason Reeves who's associate
director of computational biology
a little bit about Jason so um Jason is
responsible he and his team is
responsible for developing analytical
solutions for Nana strings technology
Access program for the geomix digital
special profiler as well as the cosmic
spatial molecular Imager
as well as data analysis services that
support academic and Industry
Partnerships across oncology rare and
infectious disease and neurobiology
so thank you so much
um Jason for joining us today and we are
looking forward to your presentation
thanks Elizabeth for the introduction
and it's great to be here to talk to
everybody today I hope that everybody is
having a fantastic week and that we can
give you a little bit of insight as to
how we approach some experimental design
when we want to understand the biologies
of complex tissue structures and give
you a little bit of biology about what's
happening within the lymph node itself
during various different states and
transitions that happen within that
system
um as Elizabeth mentioned if you have
questions please feel free to drop those
into the question q a box I'll look
forward to answering those and I will
try to do so uh both either in context
or at the end of the session
so thank you again for joining us today
I wanted to start with just a little bit
of background on the lymphatic system
and some of the reasons why we want to
understand the lymph node in general and
what its role is in biology
um the lymphatic system is one of the
systems that connects the whole body
that really helps us Monitor and um
defend ourselves against pathogens as
well as regulate the development of
various different organs and prevent
cancer from forming
the immune system has had an
increasingly recognized role across the
development of many different disease
States
and the lymph node itself is is a
particular organ structure that develops
in many different locations so it's not
something that is specific to one
particular spot within the body you cut
them all over you've got them under your
chin under your armpits and what these
areas do is allow local signals or
detection of particular antigens to be
transmitted throughout the body so that
when there's a particular need to
mobilize the the immune system
you can actually do that
the lymph node as an organ itself is
complex in structure but is arrayed in a
way that creates patterns of types of
regions within the tissue
for different particular functions
um as you are closer to the edge of the
outside here in this region called the
cortex and within that is where T cells
B cells and myeloid cells come together
to interact and identify which cells
should mature to become active immune
cells
As you move further into the structure
of the of the lymph node you move into
What's called the medulla and this is
helping this structure helps organize
the overall tissue architecture as well
as helps facilitate transfer throughout
the body uh as it connects to lymphatic
draining vessels
the lymph node is a host for pretty much
every immune cell type within the body
there's a handful that our tissue
residue that never really come into
context with the lymph node but these
serve as hubs for developing immunity
um and so they are as I mentioned before
play critical role in how various
different diseases are regulated but not
just uh viral and bacterial infections
they really do impact uh how many many
different diseases uh develop and
there's growing uh evidence even in
neurobiology of how the lymph node has
direct interplay with the nervous system
so when we think about how to study this
tissue we recognize that there's a
couple different components that we need
to understand to understand the actual
functions that are being performed here
as well as how cells mature
um the first is that this organ is
composed of both key cell types that are
going to be moving throughout the tissue
as well as different structures that are
important to focus on and that you can
only really retain if you're doing an
approach that is spatially resolved
now that particular aspect is something
that has come into play over the last
couple of years
and just as a as a quick history tour of
the ways in which we've had different
Technologies for exploring
transcriptomics or proteomics it's
important to take the step back to
understand the foundations that have
been laid within the system
um in back in the early 2000s was when
we first were able to start actually
sequencing the whole transcriptome
um and this gives you the idea that you
know we can understand disease States
versus non-disease States but all we're
getting is a snapshot picture of all the
cells and all the active activation
States match together it's better than
not having anything but it's really
really coarse in terms of what you're
getting out of that in terms of
information
um and here this is lifted and adapted
from uh aviv's slide where she's
describing this is basically drinking a
smoothie you got a sense of all the
components that are in there but you
don't really know
all the different pieces of it and there
might be some that you've
underappreciate because they're not very
common
next uh the next big jump was in the
early 2010s and this was when single
cell sequencing became robust and
feasible for most folks and this now
allows you instead of drinking a
smoothie you now actually understand
which fruits went into it
but single cell sequencing on its own
does have some biases uh and it is not
always possible to capture every single
cell type that's present within a tissue
moreover it's also not possible to
really know whether or not the oranges
are supposed to be sitting next to the
apples in your actual uh tissue or if if
what you're looking at is really
really representative of the structure
as a whole and so that's where spatial
biology really comes in
um we've created both the geomix digital
spatial profiler and the cosmic spatial
molecular imager to now take all the
components that we have and capture a
snapshot of where they sit
within the tissue
I'm going to tell you a little bit more
about these but I'm also going to walk
you through the tissues as we go through
this
so as I mentioned geomix and cosmics
serve different roles in terms of trying
to identify and profile transcriptomic
and proteomic profiles from tissues geox
is a multicellular profiling approach
where you can look at different tissue
types or different cell types as they
are spatially resolved within the tissue
we'll go through this as our first look
into the lymph node itself
um and then cosmics is a subcellular
platform where you're getting spatial
resolution of thousands of transcripts
at once down to the individual cell
and that'll be described a little bit
more towards the end of the talk
so I want to talk through how geomets
Works in case you aren't familiar geomix
is combines a couple different features
to really create the magic that we have
with this platform
the first is that with both of our
platforms you get a four Channel
Multiplex immunofluorescent stain so you
have an ability to physically look at
your tissue and I'll come into this for
the lymph node in just a second
it also uses a pair uh two different
types of affinity reagents whether
you're profiling for RNA species or
protein species but these are
essentially standard probes that are
standard types of reagents that are used
to profile tissue whether it's an ish
probe or an antibody that have been
barcoded with a particular oligom
nucleotide that we know the specific
sequence for
that barcoded sequence is attached with
the UV photo cleavable Linker and that's
how we specifically allow you to capture
which molecules are present within a
given part of the tissue
and then the last component that's
really critical is that we array a
series of micro mirrors that allow you
to tune where you shine light
so the geomix platform is by definition
a microscope microscopes do a great job
of Illuminating tissue and this micro
mirror array allows us to specifically
control light down to a micrometer
so by having this combination of both a
multiplex if a micro mirror and these
Affinity reagents we can now start to
profile specific regions of interest
within the tissue
now within the lymph node we purchased a
series of blocks that were from inflamed
lymph nodes from patients that had been
harvested without any complications or
disease that has been noted
um specifically and what we wanted to do
was look throughout the tissue and
identify key structures that we could
start to profile and understand
differently I want to make sure that you
understand that there's going to be a
couple different experimental designs
that we're pursuing across these
different samples
the first one is to try to understand
how T cells and B cells are particularly
impacted as they move throughout both
the cortex and the medulla we have
regions that are t-cell-rich zones that
are collected in the cortex as well as
regions that we've segmented where we
look for where we draw a square polygon
in the middle of the medulla here and
we're segmenting using the
immunofluorescent staining that we have
to collect specific cell populations
now I'm going to talk through a number
of these findings and and one thing that
I want to mention is that all the data
that's being collected for this is
available on our website
so if you want to explore this more I'll
show you how to do that later on in the
top
so just to emphasize again the types of
regions that we're collecting here we've
got three different regions that we're
just hand drawing the shape and we're
going to collect it specifically from
the tissue we've got regions that are T
cell Rich and B cell Rich and we also
have regions that are should be heavy in
stromal cells and these are called
trabecula
we also as I mentioned Place several
Square regions within the medulla and
have segmented those into T cells
fibroblasts and B cells simply based on
the staining and what you can see the
difference in terms of how these are are
built the the ones collected at the top
collect every single cell within a
region regardless of its cell type the
ones that are from the segmented
profiling are going to be focused really
on the cells that specifically Express a
particular immunofluorescent marker
now we wanted to go through and confirm
that what we're collecting makes sense
biologically and can help us drive how
we look at comparing these different
regions of Interest
the first way that we did this was
comparing our tissues to the human
protein Atlas the human protein Atlas is
a compendia of tissues that have been
collected over time
and which have been profiled with as
many antibodies as possible and so we
can test whether or not we're seeing
expected staining patterns within our
tissue
I'm going to focus on the segmented
profiling because those are regions
where we should expect to have really
strong composition of individual cell
types
so the first example is that to go
through and look at CD3 streaming now
CD3 and cd8 are both markers of T cells
and we should expect to see those
enriched specifically within the CD3
compartment that we specifically
collected
here what we're observing is staining
that's shown from the human protein
outlets and on in the middle is the CD3
expression from our particular
experiment where you can see that the
cd20 and SMA positive regions have very
low staining of CD3 while we do get
specific collection of CD3 itself the
same is true for cd8 which is a marker
of activated T cells
we also went through and collected
b-cell Rich regions so we're showing
similar plots as has been shown here
to uh to the previous one
um where we were looking at T cells and
so this again confirms that the
collection that we've got is both
specific and sensitive to the markers
that we anticipate to see in these
regions
finally the SMA specific regions are
regions that should have high degrees of
fibroblasts and cells that are adjacent
to those fibroblasts and make up
structural components within the tissue
and what we can see here again is that
SMA is specific but we also get genes
like aquaporin which should be
interacting with the stromal cells and
maybe more highly present within that
that type of tissue structure
all of this is really important to make
sure that we understand that the system
has been performing as expected however
none of these are particularly striking
or novel findings but what this has
enabled us to do is to feel confident
that when we do see something within our
within our study it's likely going to be
driven by real biology
um and the human protein Atlas is a
great place to validate any of the
findings that you have
um if you're working on our system
um the benefit of using this as a
validation source is that it is the
functional readout as a
post-translational readout uh while we
are also profiling just RNA species
expression
now as I mentioned we're profiling RNA
and so we're really trying to get it not
just any one individual marker we're
actually profiling the whole
transcriptome at once and so we can now
start to ask questions as to what
changes when you want to compare
different regions that are enriched with
certain cell types here we're looking at
on the left hand side of the volcano
plot we're looking at which genes are
enriched when you're in the in the B
cell zones that we collected which were
highly um highly focused around regions
that were Rich for B cells themselves
but not specifically segmented on them
and on the right you're looking at T
cell in Rich zones now as before we're
seeing specific markers that we know to
be expressed by B cells or by T cells
such as cd20 cd19
cd79a should all be directly expressed
by B cells but we're also picking up
markers of genes that help us understand
how the cells are polarized and how they
move throughout the tissue
um
so for example CD3 the CD3 Rich T cell
Rich regions also show examples of
expression of markers like ccl19 and CCL
21 which are genes that are specifically
involved with chemotaxis of T cells
themselves
and are known to specifically be
enriched within
the the lymphatic system because they're
involved with T Cell maturation during
the process of antigen presentation
so I want to make sure that what's
emphasized here is that while we can
specifically look for Regions that are
are defined by
immunofluorescent markers what we get is
a snapshot not just of those genes and
of those particular markers that we know
should be there
but a deep dive into all of the
particular expression patterns that may
underlie the functional biology that
we're looking into
now this is an example of the T Cell
versus B cell Zone I also wanted to show
what the data looks like for the
stromal-rich regions when you compare
for example the CD3 plus Cells versus
the SMA cells and again as we mentioned
we do see enrichment of genes such as
CD3
ctla4 but we also see aquaporin became
one and a number of markers that are
specific to extracellular Matrix showing
up within the regions collected that
were enriched for SMA
all of this data is really interesting
in that you can you can start to peer
through this and identify novel
particular genes that you may not have
identified before from bulk or single
cell profiling but it does also allows
us to take a next step further into
understanding what this tissue
functionally does when we're looking at
our expression patterns here one of the
common ways in which analyzing data from
either bulk or single cell profiling has
been performed is to contextualize Gene
sets by comparing them to previously
annotated Gene set ontologies
and so we've performed a similar
analysis here we've used tools that have
been developed specifically for
rna-seq and single cell seek to do this
but they're completely appropriate to
use with our data type as well here
and the one that we're going to use
first is going to be using single cell a
single sample Gene set enrichment
analysis
what this is going to do for us is now
we can take a look at every region that
we've profiled and ask the question
which pathways are particularly enriched
within that region we can add we can
look at the genes relative expression
and abundance within our tissue and use
this to score the genes as a set
themselves what you can see within this
particular graph is that there's a
number of genes that make or a number of
Pathways that make particular sense for
each particular structure and we do see
enrichment and specificity for these
structures each of these Pathways was
identified as being differentially
enriched within a given
within a given type of region that was
collected at an FDR of less than 0.05
um and so you can start to look through
this list and see some really
interesting biology that may not have
been able to fall out at the individual
Gene level but might be more apparent
when you're looking through a gene said
ontology here whether that's how how the
tissue would respond to a viral
infection whether that's
um that's maturation of
um maturation of B cells or CD um
cd28 cross ligation
I want to emphasize that all of this is
entirely agnostic to
um uh we we did not set up a model to
specifically assume that any of these
genesets were enriched all we did was
ask which Gene sets are differential
between these different structures
um one thing I noted at the onset was
that we did this type of study across
multiple different blocks we actually
purchased five different patient samples
and were able to run this study across
not just one sample which is what's
being shown here where we're collecting
five or six regions per particular
structure we also were able to do this
across the entire cohort and again any
of these types of analyzes are robust to
being able to look across cohorts and
the benefit of this is that it allows
you to feel confident that the results
that you're getting aren't driven by a
given a single given patient
um when we're doing the analysis using a
single sample we can use tests that are
usual and within the within a statistics
space for most biological applications
you can use things like anovas or
t-tests when we move to a space where
we're looking at replicated samples
within a given patient we do move to
more advanced models and we have
documentation on how to do that within
our systems both on our website where we
discuss some of the analysis as well as
on bioconductor where we have several
packages for data analysis directly for
geomix if you'd like to learn more about
that feel free to reach out to us
so this is one way of looking at the
tissue but as you can imagine there's
multiple different regions within the
tissue that are particularly important
one of one of the things that we didn't
emphasize a whole lot within this was
the the structure that is where a lot of
the immunological action happens in
terms of where cells mature and how the
body filters through and looks for
region
antigens that are specific to viruses
and bacteria
so in addition to
um the previous profiling structure we
also undertook a profiling where we're
looking specifically at the germinal
center within the within the tissue
um this is looking at the gross level of
overall what's happening within the
germinal center as a whole and I'll come
back to further refining this later on
and talk because this is this is a very
high view of what's happening in a
terminal Center but we can take even
further granular Cuts within the
structure
here we're showing an example of a
tissue where we've got germinal centers
that are these round structures where we
go in and profile those round structures
and then segment them further but we're
also collecting mantle Zone B cells
which are B cells that live adjacent to
the terminal Center as well as T cell
Rich zones that are adjacent to um the
terminal Center as well so that we can
understand some of the changes that
happen between and across these
different tissues between and across
these different structures
so I want to show what's happening
within this segmentation because we did
a couple specific tricks here that we
wanted to make sure you understood the
germinal center is composed of a large
number of cell types and as a basically
the meeting ground where everybody comes
together and decides what the plan of
action should be when faced with a new
antigen
it's composed of as I said several
different cell types but we're going to
focus on three of the ones that really
do a lot of the work at heavy lifting
within the germinal center
um in terms of setting up an immune
response
the first of these is myeloid cells that
are actively presenting antigens at
helping T cells understand what they
have observed out within the wide world
of the body we're marking these cells
with cd11c and cd11c marks primarily
dendritic cells it may also capture some
other myeloid cells that are in
different stages of differentiation
the next cell type is the B cell and
again this is another antigen presenting
cell it's also a memory cell that helps
the body understand what long-term
pieces of information it's seen in the
past and so the combination of these two
cell types really helps T cells
understand what they should be attacking
and what they shouldn't be attacking
and so the final cell type that we have
profiled here is the T Cell which is CD3
positive so these three cell types are
the ones that we're going to focus on
here and we're going to look again for
differences that we observed between
them and across them
so the first again is to prove to
ourselves that we do feel like we're
getting strong and specific staining of
uh of the different markers when we
looked previously at CD3 and CDA we saw
that both of those were enriched within
CD3 positive segments
one thing that is different here and I
want to highlight is that germinal
centers don't typically have a lot of
cd8 positivity and this is again
something that we can see directly
within the human protein Atlas
and it's also something that we observe
on the right hand bar plot here cd8
expression is differentially enriched
within the CD3 positive cells but it's
not very high and not very significantly
separated from the other compartments
this is simply because we don't see a
lot of CDA positive cells within the
terminal Center itself
as they are not the ones that are are
really doing the business end of trying
to identify whether or not an antigen
has been presented seen and is worth
attacking
they get mobilized in the adjacent
regions to the terminal Center itself
similarly uh when we're working through
understanding the the biology of which
cell types from the myeloid lineage
might be present we also see direct
evidence that
cd11c is stating specifically as we
would expect its protein marker is
called or it's RNA Gene symbol is called
idgax but the protein name is cd11c so
when you're looking these up in the
human protein Atlas this is how you
would find it
uh similarly myeloid cells and
macrophages are commonly marked by a
gene called cd68 and we see specific
enrichment of that with cd11c
compartment suggesting that these are in
fact Violet cells that we are picking up
and that there may be some macrophages
also within this particular compartment
of the tissue
now I wanted to give you one example
here again of the type of work that we
can do when we do when we're trying to
compare different cell types here we're
looking at CD3 versus cd11c to see
what's happening within this within this
structure of the tissue one thing that
is obvious and easy to note here is that
well previously we had seen that um
ccl19 at CCL 21 were being enriched
within the T Cell zones that we had
previously profiled in the germinal
center that's not a function that is
really being performed by the T cells
themselves CDs ccl19 is sort of sitting
at the within the middle of the volcano
plot here
um
that's because these cells have already
migrated in they don't need to express
it and they're they're not actively
pushing that particular axis however
what we do see is in strong enrichment
of genes like ctla4
as well as genes such as il-18 within
the dendritic cell compartment
and both of these are really critical in
terms of again making sure that the
right cell types are present as well as
making sure that the T cells that are
present within a region are not going uh
overly active
so ctla-4 was a gene that was identified
previously it was actually discovered
really within the lymph node and has
played a huge role in terms of both
immune cell development as well as
overexpression of that particular
markers but is a Target now in cancer
Therapeutics and immunomodulation within
autoimmune disease as well
we're able to directly detect this
within a single sample of this tissue
foreign
I've not been able to dive through all
the data that we have here
um and the reason that I'm not going to
go through every single piece of data
that we have within this study is
because we've made this publicly
available on our website
if you'd like to download the data or
explore it we have interactive stories
that allow you to explore the lymph node
directly on a page called the spatial
organ Atlas
um so if you want to scan the QR code
and come through that while we go
through the rest of the results you
absolutely can
there's multiple different organs that
you can can view and the lymph node is
one of five human organs that's on that
page we also have developing Mouse and
the mouse brain as well on that page
these stories allow you to go through
and look at the experimental design that
we've set up they walk you through QC of
the data and give you information about
how many genes we're detecting within
specific regions
and then we also allow you to explore
some of the high level results that are
found When comparing different regions
against each other
but and the benefit of using this is
that you also get the chance to view the
tissue itself
the segmentation strategies that have
been performed and all of the
immunofluorce and staining that has been
captured within the experiment
so I would highly recommend that if you
get a chance
to take a look through these data
because we've got plenty more results
available there and you can download and
work with the data off on your own
directly from the website as well we
make sure that all the data that's
related to these experiments is present
including
the raw count data that's generated as
well as data that has been through the
normalization process
and all of the raw images that have been
captured from our system so that you can
take those into your favorite image
viewer or editor and then move forward
with that
um
so I wanna I want to highlight a couple
things as we move this talk forward
about cosmics
um before I jump into that we did get a
question
um
about immunostaining
um and I want to go ahead and grab this
right now while we're talking about
geomix
um because I think that I understand the
question but I may need a little bit of
clarification here
um essentially the question is if Target
proteins I want to analyze happen to
co-localize after immunostaining is done
with the DSP be able to segment and
effectively collect separate samples for
posterior transcriptomics analysis
so uh after you've done the
immunostating you have the ability to
control the segmentation process however
you want it and and by that I mean you
can segment on multiple different
markers or on individual markers so if
you want to say look at
um a tumor that has T cells that are
infiltrating through it like like is
shown at the bottom of this figure below
you can create you can collect tumor
cell Rich regions using pansy K
but then use CD3 staining to exclude the
T cells that have invaded so that you
can capture those in a separate segment
or you can capture them all together as
just a tumor compartment but that
control is totally up to you
um and so I believe that that is the
question that you're after but if not
please feel free to further clarify it
in the comments as well
now as we move over to
um
the cosmics side of the house I want to
emphasize that you know we've had a lot
of success and a lot of interest in
understanding the overall tissue
structures and cellular dynamics that
are happening at Broad scales but
sometimes you really need to understand
what's happening with two cell types
interact with each other in local
regions of the tissue
as I mentioned before the way that we
set up the first germinal center
experiment was rather broad we took the
whole germinal Center and we didn't have
a lot of granularity as to what was
happening within different regions of
the tissue
here cosmics allows us to ask questions
at the cellular level of what cells are
interacting with each other and what
particular marker genes might be going
together within different regions of the
tissue
I want to talk a little bit about the
chemistry of cosmics so that you can
understand how it's similar to geomix
and and where it differs because we use
some of the same tricks as we did before
um so the first piece of information
here is that um as as with geomix you're
working off of a standard histological
slide and again you're using Affinity
reagents to understand what's happening
within your tissue
as with geomix within cosmics we only
adhere the Affinity reagents once you
never strip them off of your tissue and
they consist of standard probes similar
to ish probes or antibodies that you'd
use in other applications
the magic really happens again by the
fact that we're using
um those probes those those particular
Affinity reagents
um with barcoded sequences that we can
read out
but instead of collecting the sequences
like we do with geomix what we're doing
is going to directly image them within
the tissue
and to get the Imaging to work right we
have to do a few tricks
and again we rely on
um a couple different
assets of our reagents to really drive
forward how we
can then measure them specifically in
space
the first of these is that
instead of having a barcode that we
detach from our RNA species or from our
antibody
all that's physically conjugated
together so it's all one molecule and is
never going to break
second what we do is we use a secondary
oligo to bind to that we have regions
within the tag that is not homologous to
the RNA or the tag that hangs off the
antibody
which we call Landy landing pads where
an additional species of molecule can
bind to it directly
this species is the one that's
conjugated to a fluorophore series so
that you can specifically image whether
or not a binding event has happened
after a binding event has happened what
we'll do is a rounded Imaging where
we'll look for different colors of
fluorescent molecules showing up
specifically within our tissue
after we've done that one round we'd now
use UV light again like we do within
geomix to specifically release the
oligos using that photo cleavable Linker
we wash the tissue with a non with a
very light wash that removes any of
those fluorescently tagged oligos and
allows space for new molecules to bind
and so over a series of Cycles where we
do this flowing on of fluorescently
tagged molecules Imaging hitting it with
the UV light and then removing those
fluorescently tagged molecules we get a
series of sequences that helps us
identify where specific molecules have
been found
what this produces is a data set that's
extremely rich and looks something like
this
what you're going to be able to have
when you do a cosmics experiment is an
understanding of where individual
markers of individual genes are so every
Point within this graph represents a
particular RNA transcript that we are
confidently detecting within our tissue
the the lines around them are the cell
boundaries as I mentioned earlier
cosmics is collecting just like geomix
not just the location of any individual
ish probe but also multiplied stimula
fluorescence
as you can imagine this is generating a
ton of data I just want to emphasize
that if you're writing a whole tissue
sample you're generating millions of
cells and potentially billions of
transcripts within a single run
and so I'll come back to that a little
bit later but we want to make sure that
that doesn't become a barrier for
analysis Downstream
let's talk a little bit about the
different layers of data and how you can
use this to understand your tissue
um this is again not lymph node it's
just for the specifics of understanding
what you can do with cosmics data but
we've got a thousand Flex RNA and in r d
we've been doing some work up to 100
Plex protein I believe at launch it's
going to be closer to around 70.
um but what this is going to provide you
is within a given particular sample that
you're looking at you're going to have
at least a four Channel Multiplex if RNA
expression that goes with that at the
ish level of up to a thousand uh Plex
RNA and then you can perform Downstream
analysis that allows you to identify the
segmentation of your given cell as well
as perform analysis to identify what
cell types are present within your
tissue what their activation state is
and how they interact with each other
so all of this is generic so let's dive
into a little bit of the lymphobiology
as I mentioned before before we had been
looking at the germinal center as a
functional unit that was Indiscreet we
were looking at the whole thing all at
once
that's not how the germinal center
really functions and so we wanted to see
if there were any of our samples that
had really well defined germinal centers
and when you say a well-defined germinal
center histologically that's looking for
a germinal center that has both a light
zone and a dark Zone and the light zone
uh is where the T cells and the B cells
really mature together and they go out
from the from the terminal Center the
dark zone is where B cells specifically
proliferate and try to help produce a
mass of specific B cells that are going
to be specific to antigens that might be
presented down down the road this is
where B cells perform hypermutation on
the their particular B cell receptor so
that you have a diversity of potential
antibody producing cells
it's when they move into the light zone
that they become specific
um and so what we found was there was
one particular lymph node within our
study that had a large number of
germinal centers where we could identify
um the light zone in the dark Zone by
using staining for ki-67
um cd20 and CD3
and in this particular sample what we
did was we collected every lymph node
that we could by geomix segregating
those into the light and the dark Zone
as is sort of shown on this graph on the
right but also capturing an intermediate
phenotype knowing that we might be
seeing more specific signal if we
separate the light in the dark Zone more
consistently from each other and we
might capture biology that is only
present at the interface between these
two zones if we do separate them into
three rather than just two zones
we also took this same sample and then
profiled it with cosmics we used our r d
kits for testing for a thousand
subcellular transcripts as well as 100
proteins and this translated down then
to 27 cell types that we were able to
profile across the entire tissue
structure and here we're just showing
example expression of six of the
different transcripts that are present
within the tissue we'll dive more deeply
into some of the other results that
we're finding here
but this combination of these two
studies really starts to now allow us to
get really fine-grained understanding of
what's happening within the lymph node
germinal Center itself
now I say this but I want to really
emphasize that one thing that we spend a
fair bit of time that we do with our
systems is making sure that we're
getting robust data and so I showed you
that previous slide that showed the
lymph node sample as individual genes
this is showing it on the left as cell
types
colored uh differently by the cell type
that's assigned but it also as you can
see in this particular blow up in the
middle you can capture a light and a
dark zone of the germinal center even
just by looking at the cell types that
are enriched within that spheroid
structure but it's really critical to go
down to the segmentation level to make
sure that you've got the right cell say
cell shape to be able to call these
cells appropriately
I want to emphasize this simply because
it's where we've spent a fair bit of
time we had a poster that we released at
agbt that described our methods for cell
segmentation and the big thing that I
want to point out here is that we're not
just using nuclei segmentation we're
using a consensus model that involves
both nuclei segmentation as well as
cytoplasmic segmentation to create the
final cell segmentation model that we
work with
um we've done this within the lymph node
sample that we profiled to make sure
that if they're cells that are
irregularly shaped that we can better
profile it profiling if you'd like to
learn more about how we perform this
segmentation there's a poster from agbt
on our website that we're happy to point
you to
now I also want to emphasize that the
other piece of this when you've got a
tissue structure like this you can
basically get the cell types for free
but the reason that you get the cell
types for free is because we're working
in a space similar to what you have with
single cell seek you have data that is
physically resolved but you also have
data that's coming directly from a
transcriptomics and so you can run the
same types of analyzes that you would
with single subsequencing so here on the
on the right hand side is showing the
umap projection of these cells and their
relatedness to each other regardless of
their physical colloquialization which
is shown on the left
and again as we as we have this in hand
we use this directly for doing our cell
typing this helps us identify cells that
are specifically related to each other
and which should be biologically similar
regardless of their their physical
location of the tissue
um to prove that we've done an SL typing
that's robust and useful
we take this the next step further of
going through and comparing the cell
types that we've identified to the genes
that are most specific to these cell
types and so this is one of the qcs that
we perform in pretty much every
experiment that we run because we want
to make sure that we see the appropriate
cell type markers in specific types of
cells for example you'll see within the
middle of the graph there's this block
of red that is associated with CD3 cd8
itk and a couple other markers that we
know should be expressed across a broad
range of T cells that exist within the
lymph node
but conversely we've also got markers
that are almost entirely
um
specific and so we're able to pick up
things like vwf as being very specific
for endothelial cells uh within this
system
so I want to emphasize that this is a QC
that we run before we do any Downstream
analysis because we want to make sure
that the cell typing that we've
performed here is robust and captures
most of the data that we're looking for
now I mentioned that we collected all
the germinal centers here with geomix
and so what I'm going to talk through
over the next couple of slides is how we
approach this experiment of taking not
just cosmics data but geomix data as
well and integrating that together and
what stories we can find by doing so
so here we're going back to the geomix
data and this this graph essentially is
the three-dimensional uh volcano plot
where we're looking for enrichment of
individual Pathways in either the light
zone the dark zone or in the zone that
sits within the middle of them
now one thing I want to emphasize here
is that if if there was no novel biology
in the intermediate Zone that area would
be mostly if not entirely absent from
this graph
but for the purposes of what we're
seeing here in terms of understanding
specific biology for the light and dark
zones we can find different Pathways
that we can then map back to and
physically explore within the tissue one
example of those is cd28 code
stimulation which we then show on the
right of
but the scores for that particular
pathway being graphed physically on the
tissue in those in those breakout graphs
um below and so anything that's enriched
in yellow is being enriched within the
light zone anything that's shown in dark
blue is not really expressed and you can
see a direct gradient from dark Zone to
light zone of the cd28 co-stimulation
pathway
this is great for understanding the
overall functional consequence that's
happening within a given tissue
structure but it doesn't tell us what
cell types are actively driving that
interaction
uh cd28 is extremely well characterized
and we have some pretty good guesses as
to what cell types are going to drive
that but in addition to looking at the
overall pathway we can also do uh what
we call a ligand receptor analysis
that's spatially resolved we can look
for which cell types within a germinal
center are specifically interacting with
each other based on their proximity and
expression of ligands and receptors on
those cell types
and so here we're we're using the
physical location to drive our
understanding of which signaling
Cascades are being driven by which cell
types
uh and so for the example of cd28 we can
see that cd28 cross-ligation is
primarily happening within the germinal
center T follicular helper cells and
it's primarily being driven by its
interaction with those lights and B
cells
this is one of several different
interactions there's others in this that
make perfect sense for the biology that
we're capturing
for example icos is known to be
upregulated on T follicular helper cells
and was identified as a major driver of
maturation of the cells within the
terminal Center we see that here as well
um but as before we can use the cosmics
data to identify the players that are
really driving an interaction and then
what's shown here on the right is the
downstream consequence
so again when we had previously shown
that uh the cp28 co-stimulation pathway
is enriched within the light Zone on
this graph
we can see all of the different genes
that are specifically involved with that
within the geomix data as well if we
look at it as a heat map where here
we're seeing enrichment of cd28
co-stimulation being driven by all the
genes that are shown on the right
now the last piece that I want to
emphasize is that sometimes it's really
important to drive understanding of
biology not just at the RNA level as I
mentioned within this particular lymph
node sample we also have protein
staining that we did with the cosmics
platform as well
and one particular marker that was of
interest that we saw in previous work
within the geomix data was that il-18
seemed to be of particular interest
within the myeloid cell lineage and here
we see evidence that il-18 is also
expressed on the aisle on the myeloid
lineage and it's likely talking to B
cells within the terminal Center
so we wanted to take this the next step
further and understand do we see
evidence of localization of violating
because
um cytokines like il18
um the interleukin family especially is
highly post-translationally modified and
regulated they need to be actively
maintained and they need to be loaded
into granules sometimes or bound to the
cell membrane and so RNA expression here
may not be sufficient for proving that
this axis really is active within our
sample
so we looked within the cosmics protein
data and we asked where do we see il-18
and so this animation shows you a little
bit about which cells are expressing iol
18 these are going to be the green
arrows our myeloid cells that are
expressing il18 now I want to point out
that biolating is expressed by other
cell types but when you look for which
cell types within the germinal center
that round structure shown on the right
are expressing ilyteen it's almost
exclusively myeloid cells and so we
believe that this is indicating that
this is a novel function for Ila team
within the germinal center itself that
may have previously been under
appreciated
so with that I hope I've given you some
insights into some of the ways in which
we're exploring the lymph node right now
this data is actively being analyzed and
we're looking forward to seeing more
findings like this become validated but
we're hoping that this type of data can
show you how to use these two systems
together
um and so I'm going to end here on this
slide where we emphasize again you can
use geomix to really do high high depth
profiling of the functional consequences
of different structures within your
tissue and the interactions that happen
between different cell types at their
functional state level and cosmics can
really help you understand which cell
types are interacting with each other
and how they interplay a very deep level
this slide also emphasizes that as these
data are being collected we recognize
that there's a large amount of data
that's being produced by both of these
platforms and studies that are going to
be trans translationally driven are
going to be ones that produce larger and
larger cohorts of data
um so we're also we have also been in
the process of launching a platform
called autonomics and this is where we
will create a data hub for all of the
data collected from both of our systems
and we'll be able to analyze and
integrate this data as you work with it
going forward if you'd like to learn
more about atomics go to our website
um but I wanted to make sure that that
was something that you are aware of as
well
so with that I think we've got a couple
minutes to jump into questions
um and so uh thank you all so much for
attending today
thanks so much Jason
um great informative presentations we've
got a few questions that came through
um one of the questions that came
through is
um can you do spatial transcriptomic and
proteomic profiling with geomix from the
same uh tissue section
yeah that's a great question
um so as I mentioned before our our
protein profiling at minimum is you get
at minimum Four Color evening of
fluorescence however we recognize that
some people have very very precious
resources in terms of samples available
to them so we launched a proteogenomics
workflow where you run both of our
assays the protein and the RNA assay
directly on the same slide earlier this
year you can find a white paper related
to this on our website and there'll be
more information coming but this is
absolutely possible now with geomix to
just just use a single slide for all of
your analysis
yeah and I will add to that a question
that came in we have a webinar that's
happening next week
um on Thursday
um October 27th a week from today that's
jointly sponsored by Illumina
um and there's researcher
um sudarshan
at University of Wisconsin medicine he's
going to be talking about using this
facial proteogenomics workflow to
profile the whole human transcriptome as
well as about 150 Plex human proteins
with geomix in different tissue
structures within diffuse midline glioma
samples from pediatric and adult
patients so if you're interested in that
you can go to our website to the events
page and then click on the webinar
that's happening on October 27th and
register for that and we have timings
both for Asia Pacific as well as
America's in Europe
so another question that came through
um is the tissue destroyed after
immunohistochemistry or molecular
profiling
um and I guess this question could be
asked for both cosmics and geomix and
and in other words can you perform an H
knee or chromogenic IHC
yeah that's a great question so the way
that geomix works the only thing that
you're doing with geomix is a standard
histogram and you're only touching the
slide with light
um all you're doing is collecting things
that have physically floated off of it
so geomix is by nature non-destructive
and you can work with the tissue
afterwards the flow cell that's attached
in cosmics is a little bit beefier and
so it I believe is still non-destructive
you're not physically doing anything to
the tissue but it may be harder to
remove the flow itself for cosmics and
work with it Downstream but we have
phrygiomics had plenty of people work
with our slides after the fact and do
repeated stainings or run another assay
that they wanted to even with geomets as
well if they decided that they wanted to
expand on a previous protein panel and
use a complimentary one that they didn't
run the first time
is it excellent thank you so much Jason
um another question that came in do you
have a list of custom morphology markers
or stains that have been used
um with the geomax digital spatial
profiler
yep all that information is on our
website
um and so if you want to see what you
can what our technology access lab has
been doing across different tissue types
and across different morphology markers
I'd recommend you go take a look on our
website because that lab has worked with
many many many different types of
tissues and is great for getting a sense
as to which antibodies have worked
really well in those tissues so we
collect that information and make it
available directly to you
thank you so much Jason
um another question that came in is it
possible to use the cosmic spatial
molecular imager on tissues other than
human
the answer to that absolutely so at
launch we're producing both the human
content and content for the Mouse
um one thing that I will note too is
that just because a panel has been built
specifically for one species doesn't
necessarily mean that you need to feel
like you're limited just to that species
we have had people use the human cosmics
panel with non-human primate already in
studying the response to the Simeon
virus that is similar to HIV the SIV
virus
um so we have seen people use these
panels in new and inventive ways that we
did not uh develop them specifically for
but which we can help you understand as
you go forward similarly for geomix
um if there's a particular species that
you're working with you may well be able
to work with it with the panels that we
already have available
um last week I saw someone present
research using the mouse panel with
hamster and so I want to make sure that
you understand that there's there's lots
of opportunities both in terms of us
producing panels that have directed
content for our specific species but
also for potentially using the panels
that we have for cross-species analysis
as well
excellent thank you so much Jason
um so we have just a minute or two for
an any additional questions
um we've gone through all the questions
that were submitted um during the course
of the webinar presentation but if
um there are any of you that have any um
you know burning unanswered questions
that you'd like to get out now's your
chance so I'll give a minute or two if
you want to type in your questions
I also want to mention that this
presentation will be available on demand
after the fact today so um if you have
any colleagues who are planning on
watching this but weren't able to attend
or if you have colleagues that you think
might be interested in this presentation
please go ahead and forward them on the
link to the registration page
all right I think that concludes the Q a
portion of the webinar I want to thank
everyone for joining us
um to listen to this presentation and
again I'd like to thank you Jason for
joining us this fall
it was great talking to you all today I
hope that this has been informative for
everyone and I hope you have a lovely uh
afternoon or morning depending on what
time zone you're in
great thanks everyone bye-bye